so we're gonna do chemistry today just
kidding I can't do any chemistry but
this one is for the chemist because
we're gonna talk about something called
the centrifuge problem okay so the
centrifuge is this thing that chemists
used to take test tubes and they spin
them to separate the contents of the
test tube because it's something that's
spinning at a very high speed it needs
to be balanced in order to work
effectively and so here's what the
centrifuge problem is if you have a
centrifuge we say n holes let's say six
and you have K test tubes is it possible
to balance the centrifuge
that's the question let's assume they're
evenly spaced and on the edge let's
assume the test tubes all have the same
way it's that kind of thing just to sort
of idealize the problem it's hard enough
as it so that's the problem so if you
look at this example so I've drawn this
example with N equals 6 if K was equal
to 1 we have no chance if you only have
one test tube and you try and balance
this thing you're never gonna make it
work
right because one side will be weighted
because it's got the only test tube in
there so we can't balance it with one
right but we can balance it with two we
just put them opposite each other
okay so k equals 2 we can do and
similarly for 3 you could imagine
putting one here one here and one there
and then the centrifuge will be balanced
because they're evenly spaced along the
border and so k equals 3 we can do it
and for K equals 4 you might not see
right away that K equals 4 can be done
but here's the thing k equals 4 trying
to balance that is the same problem as
trying to balance k equals 2 right
because if we have six spots total then
missing two spots has the same weight
balances filling two spots alright so if
K is equal to 4 we can do it and maybe
you either see that directly or you can
think of it as being sort of the
opposite of doing two test tubes right
so rather than filling two I'm leaving
too empty so if one of them balances it
then so will the other okay so yes we
can do k equals 4 and for k equals 5
though we again have no chance for the
same reason as k equals 1 which is that
if we leave one empty then there's no
chance of balancing this thing and of
course with 6 then we just fill every
spot so right away if
six we see that one in five are the bad
configurations everything else is okay
and if you're me and you like prime
numbers the first thing you think to
yourself as well I see exactly when it
can be done it's when K and n have some
common factor right because one in six
they don't have a common prime factor
five and six don't have a common prime
factor but every other number on this
list does have a common factor with six
that was my guess when I first saw this
problem and before I tell you how well
my guess does let me point out two
things so one is that we've already
discussed which is doing this for K
tubes is the same as doing it for n
minus K tubes all right so if I can do
it for safe and a six if I can do it for
one I can do it for five if I can't do
it for one I can't do it for five and so
on so that's one thing to notice maybe a
more interesting thing to notice is that
we can add up configurations right so if
I can balance some number of tubes okay
put them in the centrifuge it's balanced
now if I have additional tubes and I can
balance those then just add them in and
I again stay balanced right because it's
like adding zero to zero if you were
balanced and then you add another
balanced configuration on top of it you
stay balanced if we want to think about
the K equals for example another way to
think about it is two plus two I put one
configuration here that's balanced and
then I can choose any other
configuration that's balanced for the
other two and this will always work this
adding configurations so long as there
is room for it in this example the
numbers are small and it's kind of okay
there's a lot of room in the centrifuge
but it's not always gonna be true okay
okay all right so here's why I'm wrong
let's do an example with 12 spots let's
pretend these are all evenly spaced like
before and so now we have N equals 12
and I claim that we can actually balance
this with seven tubes
no common factors with 12 in fact it's a
prime number and it's not any of the
Prime's that divide 12 and it looks kind
of weird right like I can't really
visualize putting seven dots in here to
balance this thing but think about what
I said a minute
about adding configurations if I can do
three in a balanced way and I can do
four in a balanced way as long as I can
put them in here so they don't overlap
then I can do it and that's exactly how
we'll do this because three divides 12 I
can just put them every four spots so
there's three that are balanced and same
thing with four I can just put them
every three spots and get something
balanced so we'll put say one here one
two three one two oh that's not gonna
work it's already filled right so let's
start again
so can I do it by skipping every three
well if I start here I run into a filled
spot we already tried starting here and
I ran into a filled spot if I start here
I'm gonna run into a filled spot over
here so that configuration isn't gonna
work but it turns out there's actually a
different four configuration that will
work and the reason we know that is
because 4 is 2 plus 2 right so let's not
do 4
let's do 2 pairs of opposite tubes
here's one opposite pair and here's
another opposite pair and so even though
this looks kind of strange I guess we've
got 3 here and then 2 spaces and then
1/2 and then a space even though this
configuration looks kind of strange we
know for sure it's balanced because it
was the sum of three balanced
configurations yeah it's not obvious
even after you do it looking at it
you're like I don't know how do I tell
but because we built it up from balanced
configurations we know that it's
balanced so when you say balanced just I
could I could pin yes that's right
that's right I mean if you want to talk
about centers of mass and that kind of
thing you should probably talk to a
physicist for me I'll tell you the
mathematical interpretation of this
we've talked about complex numbers
before and we've talked about the
complex plane before so remember a
complex number is a real number plus
another real number times this eye and
the way we visualize it on the plane is
just using the coordinates for the first
and second real number which I've
written is a and B so here's my like a
and B so if I draw a circle on this
plane that centered at 0 and goes
through the point 1 then I can draw this
centrifuge as a bunch of points on this
circle let me do the 6th one it's
easier and it turns out that you can
always write these complex numbers in
terms of the first one so let's say this
is Z then this is Z squared this is Z
cubed which is minus 1 actually this is
Z to the fourth and this is Z to the
fifth and so the mathematical
translation of this problem is can I add
together powers of that one number Z and
get 0 our very first configuration this
was when we had four tubes in six spots
right this is the same as saying so I
have to rotate this picture a little bit
let's say this is my Z this is the same
as saying Z plus Z squared plus and then
I skipped a spot and then Z to the
fourth plus Z to the fifth is equal to
zero for that particular complex number
ok and so the way that you actually
prove this is by showing that certain
combinations like this of powers of some
complex numbers can add up to zero but
let's actually go back to the original
thing so we thought maybe at first that
the answer was having a factor in common
a prime factor in common now we know
that that's not true but it turns out
that your next guess is true which is if
you think about this process what did we
do we took the number of tubes we had we
broke it down into prime factors and
those we knew we could balance right
just by spacing them evenly as long as
there was no overlap and it turns out
that's exactly when this will work is
that you can balance the centrifuge if
and only if both the number of
test-tubes you have which I've called K
and the number of empty spots which is n
minus K can be written as sums of prime
factors of n so let's look at this N
equals 6
so 1 is not possible to write as a sum
of prime factors of n because the prime
factors are 2 and 3 remember we need
both K and n minus K to be written that
way so 2 can be + 4 is 2 plus 2 3 can be
n minus K is 3 which is also the prime
factor of n K equals 4 we've already
checked an N minus 4 is 2 we've already
checked that 1 2 5 can't be done even
though 5 is 2 plus 3
- five is one which can't be written as
a sum of prime factors of n and so this
condition of whether or not the number
of test-tubes and the number of missing
spots can be written as a sum of prime
factors of the number of holes is
exactly when you can balance a
centrifuge which is something we
understand really well right so this is
always useful in sort of geometry of
that kind of study if you can change
something just a little bit and get back
to something you understand really well
so there's a natural way to view this
thing